Bud Light a popular beer brand faced
backlash and a boycott after sending a
personalized can to a transgender
dilemovany we all know that story The
Boy kind of significant impact on Bud
Light sales which dropped more than 28
percent compared to the previous year
that's a lot 28 that's a third in an
effort to recover the company plans to
include Bud Light in its sponsorship of
a veterans organization and focus on
television commercials highlighting
themes like football and country music
so for me one more in Dallas we're
standing at this beautiful hotel
Thompson we're at the suite all the way
at the top it's the corner Suite massive
Suite beautiful place and I'm trying to
be hospitable to Tom and here's how Tom
reacts very disappointing go ahead and
play the clip
when you stay in a penthouse like this
all the way at the top
you got to get Tom the right kind of
drink Seven can you please serve Mr
Ellsworth the proper drink that's right
this was not set up
mourning us and take your uh no what is
it we can't see it no I won't even touch
the bottle what I can't see it what is
it Sam doesn't know the difference
are you joking Tom
I will not touch the bottle touch it no
I'm just talking tom are you being
serious I'm being deadly sure what do
you have a part just a beer
no it's not a beer you know how you make
Bud Light you know how you but like tell
us you let a horse drink Coors and put a
bucket underneath and the first filters
the cores and that's how you make butter
wow see that's why you're uh
what what is going on with Bud Light
what do you want to tell us about Bud
Light here well I I'm disappointed
um a little bit in corporate leadership
you know I do case studies look at
corporate leaders and stuff and how you
lead to turbulent times and right now
you've got the CEO Budweiser saying it
was one can it was one picture we were
we didn't have a contract well wait you
didn't have a contract did you really
was a handshake agreement yeah exactly
right and it's a and there was one
person that was in the Marketing Group
and we shot her and we shot her boss and
we are getting back to where it was it
was and so you see what the CEO is doing
is trying to rinse responsibility off
the organization and and not only have
they thrown the marketing person and her
boss under the bus they're backing up
the bus going back back and forth to
make sure they're dead and that is
what's happening it's really number one
the best thing to do is to say you know
what my team made a mistake and the buck
stops with me and I'm the CEO here and
you know what we're always trying to
Market and we're trying to Market to
various groups this was a freaking big
bonehead error and you know what we're
stepping back from it and this is how it
happened instead wait oh it was only one
can and it was only one uh one incident
and and there was only one person and
she didn't have permission from her boss
does that sound like a weak you know
leadership you do the Vault conference
you talk to leaders all the time pat
does that sound like a weak leader
running from blame or a strong leader
come into the microphone you know you
know what this last time you and I had a
very good conversation together for 45
minutes okay and we're watching a Miami
Heat game he's giving me commentary I
needed help so he's kind of telling me
watch this place all this stuff but I
told him something last night I said you
know in life here's what mistake we can
make and you shouldn't make
you have to take a stand and have a
position
when you take a stand and take a
what happens next is there is opposition
you take a position there is opposition
position opposition great that's natural
hey I think Michael Jordan's the
greatest of all time you're a [__]
LeBron's the greatest of all time that's
opposition I think the Yankees are the
greatest organization of a Steinberg are
you kidding me it's really the Dodgers I
think I'm a Jewish the Muslim this
Christian did you know that that's the
opposition right okay Bud Light took a
position Their audience are male
white military
wanting to drink last thing they want to
think about is just politics they just
want to drink have a good time they love
America they want to go to a bar it's
not expensive beer they don't have a
good conversation most people when you
think about Bud Light you think about a
great conversation in the moment you
shared with a friend right then these
guys try to increase their ESG score
and Bud Light Anheuser-Busch ends up
having a perfect ESG score okay one of
the best ESG scores in America do you
know what but do you know what they just
did the ESU score organization came out
and said I don't know if you saw this or
not they came out and they said
uh lgbtq uh group slashes
anheuser-busch's perfect rating they had
a perfect rating after backlashing
backtracking on Villa Mulvaney's Bud
Light controversy so what are they doing
now now they're backing up and they're
saying yeah I don't know if we you know
support what they're doing out they went
from a perfect score of 100 only 20
companies I believe had the perfect
score of 100. so here's what Bud Light
did you you already had your loyal
audience that's been loyal to you for
decades but you also wanted to win over
the CEI corporate Equity index score and
increase that you know what happened you
lost both not only did you lose your
customers but you lost the people that
you were trying to please that's what
happens when you conform people see
through it and they say it's [__] we
don't like what you stand for you don't
have a backbone dude I'm stepping away
so they lose 28 you know who gained 28
all the other guys course and everybody
else your customers went elsewhere and
for the I you know America is pretty
forgiving so I think eventually they're
going to get over it and kind of be like
yeah whatever but it's going to take a
minute and the only way they can do it
is by firing the current CEO firing the
current CMO firing the VP of Ops showing
the fact that you fired everybody in
that department making a public
announcement that we don't care about
our ESG score our CEI score our di score
if you don't do that those people are
not coming back but if you do do that
and you replace them with a better CEO
better repeal marketing Better Boy
they're going to come out and say Here's
what I'm I love America here's what I
believe in and look we just want to make
good beer but let's make great beer for
many many years that's what we want to
get back to if you show that you don't
care about wanting to please these guys
I think customers will show back up but
that's going to take a year or two to do
100 and Budweiser USA is owned by
Anheuser-Busch USA is owned by inbev
which is a giant bear conglomerate that
also owns Stella Artois and many other
Corona and many other things
and What inbev needs to do and says we
didn't buy you to pee in the pool we
bought you to keep growing as one of the
dynamic brands that is that lines up
like Coca-Cola and others with the last
hundred years of Americana it's a very
American iconic brand and inbev needs to
do exactly what Pat just said said you
you and you you're done we bought you
not to do this and you guys have just
puked on your own shoes this is over so
so here's the thing so I want to give a
little bit more context of this this
actually falls in line with something
I'm launching in the next couple of
weeks so everybody like go to
stopwoke.com you you'll see what's that
woke stopwoke.com put it in the
description comments that's great that
you got that so so here's the thing and
a couple of in a couple of weeks we're
going to launch what I'm calling the
corporate fairness index okay so
stopwoke has partnered with the Rainey
Institute for Public Policy in DC we've
actually come up with methodology we're
going to announce the top five wokeus
companies in America we're also creating
a curriculum we're also creating a
curriculum yet to go into these
corporations and to say okay this is
what you do to sort of get away from
this what people don't realize about
this Bud Light thing and what people
don't realize about the dilemo of
anything and all of this other stuff is
that the Human Rights Campaign they have
something called the corporate equality
Index this is a grift they have shaken
down these corporations for the past 20
years the Human Rights Campaign calls
itself an LGBT advocacy organization it
is a far left
um Democrat Super PAC at this point that
gets 45 million dollars in Grants and
contributions in 2020. I personally know
for a fact that they have shaken down a
major Bank to the tune of nine figures
when they threaten them with dropping
their sort their score so Bud Light had
to do this in order to get one 100
rating on this corporate equality index
which is something that the HRC puts out
so the only way we can stop this like we
can tell talk about corporations or to
work all of that other stuff what we
need to do is number one
go into these corporations
um de-incentivize the importance of
something like the corporate equality
index and give these corporations an
off-ramp give them an off ramp to say
you know you can do your diversity and
all that stuff that's fine but also you
have to
um you have to sort of appeal to the
other side of the aisle as well so we do
not stop the fight against corporate
wokeness until we de-incentivize the
importance of the corporate equality
index that's why I'm launching the
corporate fairness index in a couple of
weeks
um we're going to be doing a lot of
stuff about that there's a lot of
companies that are very interested in
this and I believe that as a consultancy
um this is an Emerging Market these
companies and these corporations want an
offering they want a way out I'll tell
you I love it and by the way you know
who funds uh the HRC
Democrats open Society Foundation
Society he gave him 100 million dollars
in 2012. we're not even talking recently
100 million dollars in 2012 uh but go
ahead we're going to say and one of the
things that um is I'm going I'm
literally going to the swamp tomorrow
you know I'm hitting up donors and I'm
doing these presentations all this stuff
so when I'm hitting up donors um
especially conservative leaning Mega
donors for
um organizations like stopwoke that are
doing this stuff that we're we're
building this this corporate fairness
index up and we're going to do this work
the first thing that they say is oh well
don't we already have this don't we
already have that will I give to this
politician I give that to politician
when you said that the Human Rights
Campaign is funded by George Soros and
his open borders Society open whatever
Society
the left these people fund all kinds of
organizations to the tune of billions of
dollars and we don't have very many
things like this on
um the right that are things that are
you know advocating for our agenda and
the reason why is that we have a donor
base you know as conservatives that are
so consumed with get this politician and
get this all this other stuff the change
that needs to happen in this country
this last thing I'll say I know I've
been going on a bit of a tangent the
change that needs to happen in this
country is a cultural change it will
start with the culture and the
politicians will follow it is not the
other way around and this is what people
need to get I love it this is what I'm
going to tell you.com we got it all over
the place Rob respect to you yeah
appreciate that can we get a little
sneak preview of the top five most
companies give us something to work with
here guys I do not want to spoil
anything I got a couple places that have
the exclusive uh one place that has the
exclusive I will say that these are
companies I know that the the top five I
know two in the top five are household
names household names uh so so I hate to
disappoint you but what we did is the
last uh three months we've been trying
to increase our ESG score and our CI
score and this is what I'm here yes no
no this is what we did yesterday if you
want to if you want to play this clip uh
to try who is it yeah who knows hey guys
what's up Pap what's up guys oh my God
what's up
chicken legs
[Music]
sponsorship holy that's a good look
that's a good you just increased our Esq
score you're amazing I love you guys
it's crazy the heat was walking around
like that all day yesterday in the
office I'm like he comes in I'm in the
conference I'm like bro what are you
doing
he's like we're doing a skit I'm like
okay makes sense so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]